why isn't he left focusing on ending
slavery across the globe it still goes
on
everywhere if you believe that it's our
moral duty to intervene as the caretaker
for planet earth
why not focus right now on fighting
actual systemic
chronic deadly ongoing non-stop human
trafficking and slavery of today
question of the day uh how much do you
feel
you owe in reparations if you were to
put a number on it
exactly option of not supporting
reparations not on the table
how much do you think you owe dollars
and cents
please comment below the context of this
is of course in recent town halls
all of the dnc candidates have uh talked
about their support for
reparations if reparations are not part
of your plan to end the wealth gap for
black people
what is good good question uh in the
household jackson lee is each lucid and
i have said
that if the house and the senate pass it
i will sign and also or
of massive income and wealth disparity
we have another level of disparity
between black and white do you support
financial reparations
i support that we study that we should
i like that what a fine line played out
and how it should be worked
i believe it's time to start the
national full-blown conversation about
reparations
in this country
this is also known as democrats the
midwest can suck at conversation
yeah all but guaranteeing another
election for donald trump so here's the
thing this whole concept
is based on the premise that there is a
feasible reparations plan i want to go
through a few claims with reparations
we've talked about slavery we've talked
about discrimination in general not
specifically reparations because it used
to be kind of a joke
in the barbershop film where did that
come from and al sharpton would talk
about but we weren't
really talking about making this
generation of people just pay out money
um so it's based on this idea that
there's actually a feasible plan for
reparations
here's my question how really
who would qualify for reparations all
african americans just those who can
provide gene
geological evidence that their ancestors
were slaves who would pay all americans
you're gonna tax a new
first generation low-income latina no
role in slavery she have to pay for
reparations
should we just give a grant to anyone
pushing a mixtape call it even
you know should should my family who
wasn't even here in the 1800s have to
pay reparations
well i don't i don't know this is the
question i have to pay myself do you
just tax white people
do you have to get documentation proving
that their ancestors were slave owners
and what about the black people to send
it from black slave owners they write
themselves a tax refund
how do you know that this plan for
people who are listening
how do you know it's completely
unmanageable watch the candidates
try to answer with any concrete details
as to how it would work don't take my
word for it
the senator harris incident award have
both kind of spoken out and said that
they agree with some form of reparations
well but the question is what
we i'm not dodging the question the
question is what do we mean
i haven't answered it
by doing the dodge the bill
in the house to appoint a congressional
panel
to of experts of people who are studying
this who talk about different ways we
may be able to do it
point oh look i think that we have got
to address that
um again it's back to the inequities
they're
through you know look
this is what political doubles speak
this is something that it's based on
this it's predicated on the idea that
reparations are necessary because even
today's generations this is what i got
into
it with aoc over on twitter today's
generations are still filling the
negative systemic ramifications of
slavery right this is the argument
this is important to understand here the
race wage gap
is a lot like the gender wage gap it's
just a flawed general average comparison
it doesn't take into account college
degrees
it doesn't take into account hours
worked it doesn't take into account
the field of work just comparing annual
earnings of different races sure
we see that african americans black
americans people of color
whatever you want to call them 73 of
what whites make but like the wage
okay if we dig a little deeper average
annual income increases with age okay
this is something that we know that's
true
it peaks in the 40s 50s the median
minority age for black people
for white people it's 43. doesn't matter
what race by the way people in the early
30s make about 75
of what people in their 40s do wage gap
between blacks and whites starts to
close when you look at that
we can get really nerdy about this here
we can get into a bunch of reasons as to
why the wage gap
the race wage gap exists but is here
here's something important is there a
direct comparison
right do we have a direct side-by-side
comparison of people with the same
degree working the same job well
glad you've asked when we compare whites
and blacks based on their education
levels we see that wage cap shrink even
more
it reverses in some demographics black
women with advanced degrees actually
make more
than white women with advanced degrees
african americans with doctorates make
more than white americans with doctrines
now not across the board i'm not saying
this isn't every case hashtag not all
and i know some people will argue that
systemic discrimination
that's it keeps black kids out of
schools that they weren't able to get an
education until recently well you know
what
there's something now called affirmative
action and if you look at affirmative
action at colleges
it's easier for black students to get in
on a per capita basis
than white people there are race-based
scholarships that help with the cost
lower wages in african-american
households
largely due to choices made by the
current generation i should specify this
was different i think you would
acknowledge this bill this is different
before when you talk about people who
didn't have the right to vote yeah of
course that's going to
you talk about people who didn't have
the ability to go to the same colleges
that's not what's happening right now
example one of the biggest determining
factors of course poverty having
children out of wedlock
occurs disproportionately in the black
community right look at
the civil rights movement they made
great strides reducing discrimination
rate of out of wedlock birth skyrocketed
and here's something else half asian
bill will like it though they're not
necessarily your
your clan to use the word let's compare
this with another minority group
one with particularly strong marital
rates the japanese
and i know that some of you are going to
be saying well they haven't faced the
same discrimination to you
i would say google world war ii
sean king let's look at japanese
thing u.s born jeff they make a median
income of almost a third
more than your average american so this
this is what's important to me this idea
that slave reparations is complete
it's a workable concept it's based on
completely faulty evidence
and this is one hypocrisy that i rarely
hear mention when we're talking about uh
reparations which stands out at me the
most the politicians who advocate for
this the same people believe that it's
also our moral duty to pay for nations
abroad right they talk
someone sat down to change my mind like
well you know instead of building a wall
why don't we help these
countries in mexico and central america
and south america well how do you mean
by
giving them more money then they
wouldn't want to come here so they have
no problem spending money abroad
okay so by their logic which number one
it's morally imperative for us to help
other nations with our wealth and then
number two the reason they support
reparations is because
they believe it's history's greatest
evil the united states history's
greatest evil
right here's my question why aren't the
why isn't left focusing on ending
slavery across the globe it still goes
on
everywhere like all the time if you
believe that it's our moral duty to
intervene as the caretaker for planet
earth
why not focus right now on fighting
actual systemic
chronic deadly ongoing non-stop
human trafficking and slavery of today
we could do
by the way we could be far more
effective in doing that than providing
retroactive disaster relief for which we
we can't even account we can't control
and by the left's logic it'd be pretty
hard you know
it'd be pretty hard here to argue that
we need to place a priority on
reparations in the form of free college
health care housing to people five
generations removed from any actual
slavery
in the face of actually being able to
end slavery abroad
anybody saying am i missing this is
there something that i'm missing
no i think he hugged me now if they were
non-interventionists if he said well
hold on what do we do
if they said it's not our job to pay for
the world well fine
i get why you don't want to go in and
bust down the door of a slave owner but
you do believe that we should spend
money everywhere else
and you think that slavery for which 600
000 people died in the united states is
our greatest evil why don't you stop
it right now but i i don't have money
though
if we do have plenty of money and by the
way if if we see that black americans
uh have the freedom of choice and they
get to continue to improve their
economic situation as we see let me
posit something else to you here's a
clip of bernie
radical socialist dwight d eisenhower
was president
i think the highest marginal tax rate
was something like 90. it was 90. when
you think about 90
you don't think that's obviously too
high no
i don't know the question there is you
don't think it's obviously too high in
other words he's trying to get
your honor leading the witness do not
believe that 90
is obviously extreme no
the defense is wrong [ __ ]
okay so let's say for a second a black
american
gets himself into the top one percent
and that means that the annual household
income is somewhere
depending which numbers you use 250 000
400 000 a year let's just assume that a
black man becomes a moderately
successful
lawyer or doctor right lawyer doctor
pretty much automatically one percent
as long as you're in your 30s 40s and
you have it from a decent school and
bernie wants to take
90 percent of what that black man earns
effectively forcing said black man to
work at the hands of the government
should he want any future wages for 90
of the remaining fiscal year
how is that not slavery okay if you like
this video
you know you watch videos on youtube if
i were jimmy kimmel if i were stephen
colbert
or trevor noah i would tell you to
subscribe but i have no corporate
overlords who demand that i do
this demeaning promo i do the demeaning
promo because i choose to subscribe or
hit the notification bell because i need
you i need you please do it